hello and welcome to this video
Matt Holland does he give me a pond and
he does
now people struggle with this summer we
now in the peas again 95 give me the
night
give me the night it doesn't know what
what a disappointment
hmm no of course not it's kind of
understandable yeah you cannot expect
that people blunder like into pieces of
all the time I mean it happens quite
frequently okay now this is certainly a
bit more comfortable for wide
c5 you know a development is a bit a bit
slow
you
hmm Sibbett on the slower side
whoopty one
you know okay so let's say I take
you
not so happy with this but maybe I'm
okay
he takes with the poem that I did not
expect a fortnight takes an IT group
takes
try to exploit the better development
this is fine for white but not something
that scares me much
in this iqp position I already have some
pieces traded no way like one yeah we
have got the light squared bishop strain
it but these are often important to
trade for black or favourable for black
to trade because these are often or the
white slights get bishops of a good
attacking piece
kshitij was a bit under SF side wow that
looks very passive
and I can exploit I know I can take I
can take
Dick's not chicks it's probably not good
grabbing on deform probably not
try to regroup
group this metaphor was not a phone
you
okay now taking or not on c3
I don't like it at this particular world
I wanted to go to f5 anyway so let's do
it
you
if I take I'm not
SOT with an idea Hobbit the Queen not
with a pawn then Knight c3 is good
okay what did I miss
actually even hoop shakes rook takes
pawn takes knight takes
takes pawn takes knight takes
[Music]
you
I can also do this
c3m oxy 3
me I don't see a problem
[Music]
don't see a problem ham
you
okay just moves it away I can that's
possible Queen f5
or is there some other way to use the
back rank quit
something that I have to
keep in mind as that
carancas also a little bit weaker
and Luke takes f3 that is also an
important motif that could be
could be essential later
really I can take it Wow okay and it was
still somewhat interesting before he
blundered it I mean I think I'm a corn
up for not much but still okay now the
computer likes white I'm I don't I don't
I'm not surprised
my my development is really sketchy
Queen to b3 is very good for white
[Music]
Quincy 84 that's powerful that's
powerful plane
Knight takes e4 okay one is extremely
dangerous and this is very dangerous
like this and desert Oh scary
is much more mundane juris than Queenie
to Angus
and I expect the temperature to do this
yes this Queen c7 III that was what I
expected
I have this yeah as a temple but he will
play this this and then I don't know it
seemed a little bit iffy I'm I'm a bit
behind a development and it's not easy
to play after a takes I'm quite happy I
think I'm quite well placed here to to
blockade and then I'm not scared anymore
should be too yeah nothing had many
options say you can play lots of things
that make some sense
five two five this this and now I don't
need to take but I like that
I felt D takes is just wrong and if he
takes with the Knights I'm quite happy
the Knights are just better than this
Bishop him but he took and the engine
doesn't the engine has an issue here
58
oh he believes me he just believed me
hopefully he can just do this I mean
this is just like crazy and and and of
course I totally lost oh okay
so and this then it didn't work yeah
yes I'm just I'm just totally miss
counting everything I was a total
blunder Wow
he just believed me
crazy that's crazy
you know this
I'm basically a pawn up that's really
that's really what it is there's nothing
much else going on he's still a little
bit active but I should have pretty
strong pretty good winning chances wow
what a big blunder I totally totally
blundered them and then Bishop 65 makes
no sense yeah if he can take here I was
really thinking okay I take on c3 and
somehow I even thought I could totally
crazy
okay it was a long session sometimes you
just need to know when to stop okay guys
thanks for watching